[Music]
[Applause]
May
[Music]
n is
[Applause]
more good she
will
[Applause]
[Music]
be
qu in the
louisi Jan
Paul
BB what I just told you is hello my name
is Jan Paul I am panop Scott and I'm
from Where the River I Belong To Where
the River widens that song was created
out of the water rights fighting in
standing
raw and uh we created our own so feel
free if you have a water body that you
love please feel do it yourself in your
language or whatever it is
um is that oh and it's downloaded you
can download it off our website and on a
psot nation website
oh so I've been uh work I've lived on
the island my whole life and I've worked
for the tribe for 25 years and I have
lots of stories but there's one I want
to share with you today and it was part
of the video that you saw yesterday um
one day I was in Lincoln samplin and I'm
like 34s way through in the most shallow
part of the river and I'm boating and
sitting there and I just C to one site
and I was getting ready to get my
clipboard which the papers were you know
the wrong way one big gust of wind came
blew my papers all down river the
shallow pot of the river and I'm like oh
man it's like I got I can't recreate it
and I'm like so I hurry up put the motor
down Pull up The Anchor turn on and I
went flying down the river didn't care
if I was hitting I go I got to get those
data sheets cuz they're floating down
but I got got them all
yay
yes so later on in a few years after
that we were
gifted by
an so she's GNA take
[Applause]
[Music]
over yes so um maybe Dan can finish one
last line of what was the result of that
what did you ask me to do oh to go to go
paperless yeah so no small task um so I
came on um so I'm gonna do my own
introduction in a minute here um or
right now actually so Quay in thei
Angie um new J Al lineus M and so I'm
using the language um in honor of
actually Jan's nephew especially because
he's a young language keeper on Indian
Island um and I was talking to him about
like should I use the language when I
introduced myself in presentations cuz
I'm not native and he's like yeah it's a
form of
reconciliation so this is my actually my
first time I've ever done it so it's a
little bit nerve-wracking Jen so so
hopefully I did all right um so I've
been working uh for panom Scot Nation as
our Water Resources planner since 2004
so it's a long time and we're actually s
of a um an anomaly in tribal water
programs because there's often not many
people that have been there very long so
for a long time I was a the person who
was there the least so I am helping to
leave them a legacy of good data and
management um and so I'm also here uh
shamelessly I'm G to follow Ted's
example of asking for help so um I'm
shamelessly asking if when you see this
little symbol you are more than welcome
to uh help us with r or Python
Programming to accomplish the tasks that
we're still working on um so we have
I've been using R for probably a decade
at this time but I can always use more
help so uh and I also work with some
other folks that could could as
well uh so um to give a little bit of
background um Indian law in Maine is
very complicated we'll just say that uh
but one of the things that has come out
of what is called the 1980 uh Maine land
CLA Indian CL land claim Settlement Act
I always get that wrong um so one of the
things that came out of that uh was that
sustenance fishing rights were
reserved um politically it's been a very
challenging atmosphere but that has
never been questioned um
unfortunately um many aspects of uh
current environment and politics um
impact the ability to do that um and
sustance fishing is not just a we like
to eat fish and we want fish there it is
a part of an identity uh pcot people get
their actual name as pcot people uh from
the river um so it is literally uh
everything about who they are um this is
also reflected in the notion that pancot
people see the pancot river as a
relative not a natural resource so it's
family um she is family in fact I don't
really like the English language to
describe panovscott River so she is a
river uh to whom they have a
responsibility um we actually play the
Water song in the beginning to give the
sense of a different perspective of
water um I would ask yourself to to or
I'd ask you to think think about whether
you have ever heard a song that talks
about loving and respecting and thanking
water so we try to um bring this and and
actually um hopefully give everybody
sort of a common sense of of where we're
coming
from um and so uh there's actually a
really an amazing uh book called
braiding Street grass written by a
native author Robin W Kimmer and um I
think this quote really reflects again
this responsibility in it she says skyw
woman seems to look at me in the eye and
ask in return for this gift of a world
on Turtles back what will I leave and
return and for context native people
consider the continent of what we now
call North America um as Turtle
Island another quote that I feel like uh
really sets the stage for what we're
going to talk about today is that our
relationship with land cannot heal until
we hear its stories but the question
becomes who will tell them and so Jan
and I and our other staff on the Water
Resources program have been blending try
to blend indigenous ways of knowing with
Western science and uh we actually have
a braid of sweet grass here if folks are
interested in coming up and um engaging
with it at the end we are welcome to let
you do that um but I love the analogy to
uh this River Channel right now that you
see in this picture is very is a braided
Channel according to what most people
call Rivers um so I like the analogy of
braiding together both uh both ways of
knowing but also cross-cultural dialogue
because I am not native and Jan is and
we've been spending 20 years thinking
yeah we can get through this and it's
it's really hard work and we um continue
to uh to go through our many many fun
and amazing experiences and challenges
and love each other through
it so another thing that I think Bridges
the gap between native uh indigenous
ways of knowing and Western science um
is that Rene's Brown B Brown's amazing
quote um of maybe stories are just data
with a soul uh so I really it helps me
frame my work as a non-native person
working for pcot nation and so what
we're going to do today is try to tell
you the story of what we're
doing so reflecting Jans uh losing her
data sheets um what I ended up taking on
one of the first tests I took on was to
make everything digital so we weren't
losing paper anymore um and I was
reflecting on stories that I might tell
during this presentation and I spent so
much time using a mouse that I actually
had to go to physical therapy for tennis
elbow um and so I actually ended up
getting a different uh keyboard with a
cursor like a touchpad in the middle so
that I could it could not have to
experience that again so it was a long
very long and arduous task uh but we are
now having all of our field data we are
printing labels for our bottles that
have QR codes we're scanning them in the
field we come back literally everything
is connected we check in our data we
print out chain of custodies process our
data in the lab um pre-process samples
and then process all the data in the lab
and we're still using this system that
we developed probably 15 years ago um so
as I said earlier my goal is to leave a
legacy of good data um so to do that we
have a team of folks it's not just Jen
and I uh there's three other folks um so
we're out um May to October around 134
sites not every day um but usually um at
least once a week um for most of them
taking direct measurements and
collecting water quality
samples um we also do a fair amount of
work investigating toxic levels in
various um Wildlife tissue plants as
well as sediment uh so this is what uh
we can offer the panop Scot Nation about
their safety in relation to the water
that actually gives them
life uh so our work to protect the
pancot river which is the relative and
identity of pancot people is done in the
context of recovering from C cultural
genocide can be easy for non-native
scientists to come in and think yeah I'm
just going to do some science and that's
just not the whole story so one of the
foundations of recovery is staying
together with the land River and each
other so as I always hear Jen say many
times which in in some ways is sad and
some ways beautiful we're still here and
we're not going anywhere the fact that
she has to say we're still here because
in the beginning they were it was an
attempt to eliminate them so they're
still here and they're not going
anywhere and singing drumming and
dancing together is a foundational way
that pcot people make this
happen another way is removing dams uh
pancott nation was integral in getting
two dams uh taken out of the pancott
river in the lower part uh and this is
one of the areas our programs and our
data collection can make a
difference and so this is this is a
little bit of background behind the
slide so this is actually the some
counts of fish coming back um up the dam
up the river now that the two the two
lower dams are out so they improved some
fish passage in the first first Dam that
the fish now experience and when I was
making this graph and thinking about
including it in this presentation I
thought I had this it was a little bit
difficult um had this image in my mind
of I didn't ever think that I could
actually make a graph of genocide and I
thought all of the fish that were not
able to come back up the river for more
than 100 years that is absolutely a
graph of what has happened to bonam Scot
people um but the beauty of it is that
staying together and praying and working
to do water quality monitoring work and
and taking dams out is bringing fish
back so the second uh graph down the
river Herring is the most impressive
story uh in the past year since the dam
has been taken out this past year is
even the more impressive one on average
it's about 2 and a half million River
Herring have come up the pancot river uh
as compared to literally none prior to
those dams being taken out this year it
was over 5 million so it's exciting to
say that we are recovering from
it uh another aspect that it actually
taken dams out this is a um the smaller
image is when the dam was still in and
afterward it looks like afterwards um
and we we actually collected uh Data
before and after dam removal and we
found that it actually does restore
these are run-of- the river dams which
are small so they're not a lot of
storage um but they do it does restore
the natural temperature variation
regime so as I said we're also
collecting fish cons fish samples so
from the seun fish returning to the
pancot collect them at the fish lift and
then we process them in our lab and send
them away for analysis we're also
collecting some data on fish consump uh
excuse me fish tissue analysis on fish
in lakes in our Tres land Lakes um and
so we're analyzing that data all of
these all of these analysis have been
done in r at this point in time
um and here's your first chance to think
about how you might be able to have with
some statistics we're also trying to
predict um what what um concentrations
of mercury will be in fish tissue in
these Lakes based on the Watershed
characteristics of the surrounding Lake
of surrounding the lake so it's been
it's been an interesting experience but
um we we absolutely could use some help
with that so ultimately this leads to
fish consumption advisories uh We've
made some in the past uh and so we've
actually developed What's called the
wild food safety series and it's a bit
of a balance between wanting pava people
to be safe but not wanting to tell them
to not be who they are or practice their
culture uh so we chose wild food safety
series to say yep you might be eating
fish but we want you to do it
safely the unfortunate message is seun
fish coming back up the river The Hope
was that panop people would get to more
of a traditional diet unfortunately
those fish are sometimes even more
contaminated than the non seeran
fish another thing we do is we upgrade
River classifications so in Main there's
a classification for every water body in
the state um so in 2017 one of one of
the we've done this in the past and
upgraded many hundreds of miles but the
more recent one was in 2017 we submitted
a proposal to the main Department of
Environmental Protection their last
reach was at class C and we wanted to
upgrade it to class B and so posit and
and open source tools helped us to
easily summarize this data and provide
all of this information as part of our
proposal they they accepted the proposal
and uh because we had sufficient data to
to prove it so it was exponentially
easier than in the past to prove this um
in May of 2018 they sent it out for
public comment because that's what has
to happen um and actually in April of
May in 2019 we used our data um to work
with some Casco Bay High School Stu
Juniors which is down about two and a
half hours south of us um to talk to
them about the work that we do and
actually 52 students wrote letters of
support we are happy to say that in June
of 2019 the bill passed um and the
governor signed it into
law another thing we do is we do a lot
of Outreach with students um this is
actually some of the Indian Island
School students uh the big picture is of
course of one of Jan's relatives uh
collecting the sample so bacteria
monitoring is much easier these days so
we go out and collect samples uh and
then you can see Jan helping them
process them in the top right and then
counting them and me uh talking about
how do we graph this data another aspect
of that is doing Outreach on it this is
a tableau visualization I did a long
time ago notice I would love to recreate
this and shiny I do not have the skills
to do that um so I'd like to um be able
to show where our violations are on this
you know you can click on a DOT on the
map and it filters out the data vice
versa so I'd love to be able to recreate
this in
shiny and then the broader aspect of
what we do uh is I actually as a member
of Representative of ponam Scot Nation I
sit on what a group is called tribal
exchange Network group so we support
tribes across Turtle Island or what we
usually call the United States and the
management analysis and Shi sharing of
environmental
data another chance to uh to volunteer
if you want so I'm here shamelessly
asking for help again so we actually
serve there are 576 ferally recognized
tribal Nations um so we are try trying
to get out and get training on any
aspect of data data management data
analysis um there's a wide spectrum of
skills wide spectrum of things that are
being done um so we're a small group uh
we're all sort of we call ourselves
volunteer but so we get paid by our rest
respective tribal Nation U but the work
that we do is is not um compensated for
usually uh so we do a right VAR of
things we've been holding tribal data
and Technology Academy workshops which
are carpentry workshops historically uh
we're doing data dropin sessions so
they're month monthly uh group sessions
I have personally done on my own what
other people are doing tribal assistance
but I've probably done about 200 hours
of helping people code in R uh another
interesting aspect would be to also do
python because most tribes use EZ
mapping software which has python under
the hood uh and we're actually talking
about developing our first tribal
rpython User Group in the Pacific
Northwest so this is another song by
Jan's nephew actually
gave so we are um wanting to create a
braid of stories that are meant to heal
the world relationship with the world
this's another quote from Robin W Kim's
book writing sweet grass
so we've started this and then we
started working with txg tribal exchange
L group um and then through that we've
met some amazing people Canal maraja was
one of the first carpentry teachers and
then Jess and J Jess kuny and Jan ning
were also carpentry instructors and all
three of them have helped immensely uh
ever since um and then Jac and jannis
from pit was an amazing resource to us
to get connected and be able to come to
this conference and do everything that
we've been doing um so much appreciation
for every single one of these people so
we are would love help in creating
creating the braid the stories to heal
our relationship with the world uh we
already have a lot of people doing it um
but we'd love if you want to participate
and join us we would love to have you
join
us and you can email us uh there's we
also have uh ways to sign up you can
take one of these Roes we left them over
there you can sign up or you can scan
the UR Q QR code and s up electronically
as well so thanks for having
[Music]
[Applause]
us thank you so much for a fantastic
talk um so I have a personal question I
come from Denmark we're surrounded by
water we have not been treating that
water well so and I think we're not
unique and one of the issues is that
people don't see what's underneath the
water they don't see what's in their
face in the same way that land issues
environmental land issues is visible do
you have any um do you know anything
about how to inspire the right people
when it's not in their face how do you
tell the story to inspire the change
that is
needed fantastic
yeah got to get him in the water or get
him
yeah you can't force them to be in there
but I think you can't deny something
right in your face so encourage them to
go to the river show them what's wrong
with it yeah yeah I would say that
that's exactly what Jan and I have been
doing with a lot of student groups and
people in general is Right telling the
story and building relationships um and
it's a lot harder to do something to
someone you care about again if the
river is a relative um we actually
encourage people to download the Water
song and have a relationship by playing
playing the Water song for your local
water body because that changes your
perspective a lot make an offering
fantastic thank you so much again
welcome